people probably have heard of bobaccy
this group of mathematicians uh that
came together in france to kind of
rewrite the foundations of mathematics i
remember being rather blown away when i
went into the library and seeing all of
these books by this one mathematician
brought back he kind of freaked me out
and i was quite pleased to discover oh
no this is a group of mathematicians
writing all of these but there was
actually another
interesting group in france that so
wasn't sort of inspired by the balbachi
which were called the ulipo movements
ulipo stands for something in french
which is about work for the potential of
literature it was a group of
mathematicians and writers
that were exploring how mathematics
might be used to to generate literature
almost uh
you know if you're stuck and you don't
know what to do perhaps you can use
mathematics as kind of shortcut to start
generating
interesting new ideas one of the leaders
of that group was a guy called quinoa
who was kind of amateur mathematician
interested in the balbachi group but was
really a poet
and he came up with uh an incredibly
beautiful way to be
highly productive in fact he ended up uh
being able to write a hundred thousand
billion sonnets
by tapping into a mathematical shortcut
so how did he do this well remember a
sonnet is a poem which has 14 lines it
has a particular
rhyming structure and rhythm structure
to it as well
so what he did he decided to write
10 lines
that you could choose one of those 10
lines to be the first line of your
sonnet
then he wrote
another 10 lines which you could choose
to be the second line of your sonnet so
basically he had 14 lines that he needed
to write but each line there were 10
choices okay so there are 10 choices for
each line 14 lines that means there are
10 to the 14
possible sonnets that you could write
so just by writing 140 lines
but using this mathematical idea of
randomly choosing a line
the permutations that were possible
meant with just a very small amount of
work plus a bit of mathematics he
managed to write a hundred thousand
billion i think that's ten to the
fourteen different sonnets they're not
written down anywhere though they can't
be all of them are not written down in
fact i did a little calculation to work
out okay if you said i think you
probably say one of these sonnets in a
minute we could test that a little later
i worked out if the first diplodocus
that have ever evolved started reciting
these sonnets that by now that
diplodocus might have finished the whole
lot so we're talking a a lot of sonnets
you know you might say well that that
doesn't require any creativity at all no
the creativity is actually
writing
lines of poetry that um whichever one
you choose to follow next it sort of
makes some sense um so i don't know we
could have a go at um uh doing so i've
got um from one this is the first line
and i've got ten different lines here um
so you
why don't we generate a
chronosonic and
the interesting thing is the probability
is
that this will be the first time this
will be in the inaugural event of of
this particular sonic so so you give me
um a number and i will choose that
particular line for our first line i
would like you to go through the stack
there and do
set the seventh the eighth the seventh
the eighth all the way through the stack
okay let's go for that
so
it goes like this yet rose took the
minstrel's verse without a squeeze
licks round carved marble chops on
snails full blown
the understanding critic firstly sees
while sharks to let's say potted shrimps
are prone
they both are right not untamed
mutterings
not can the mouse's timid nibbling stave
they both are right not unformed
smatterings filting the lolly country
thrift helped save
poetic license needs no strain or stress
a bird brain banquet melts bold mistress
mog
from cole parnassus down to wild loch
ness
whiskey will always wake an irish bog
ventriloquists be blowed you strike be
dumb
fried grilled black puddings still the
world's best yum
kind of curious i'm not sure i i i
understood quite what was going on there
but you could certainly hear the
sonnet's structure the rhyming structure
so he made sure that the lines he chose
um
and i think the challenge was
yeah very often we get stuck in a rut
and we sort of write things that we've
heard before
um ideas that are old and a bit
hackneyed
and i think their thought with using
mathematics as as a way to kind of push
us into something at first reading i'm
not sure i made much sense of that but
maybe we sit with it a bit and it takes
us somewhere new maybe we won't
end with that but maybe that's a
beginning to stimulate us to take us
somewhere new and i think that was their
idea to use
mathematics to generate things that
maybe we
we wouldn't come across if we didn't use
the mathematics
yeah i mean these days we have tweet
bots and things don't we that make up
tweets and things like that using
picking from lists and things like this
i mean these were pioneers i guess of
that yeah i think they were pioneers and
you know they came up with different
strategies um another one i particularly
like um
which makes you hear an old poem in a
new way was something they called n plus
seven so n stands for noun in this you
know it's already an equation we've got
n plus seven n is a noun and what it
asks you to do is to take a poem you
know
but just to shift every noun in that
poem seven along in the dictionary so
for example to be or not to be that is
the question well questioning is a noun
so if i apply n plus seven to that i get
to be or not to be that is the quiche
now that kind of uh
there's a combination of of things i
know and then a surprise in there and
it's kind of absurd um but i think it
it's interesting because it helps you to
hear the structure
but perhaps takes away meaning um i've
got another example of that actually uh
let me try and find that um in here uh i
want to go through every poem i know now
and do that and reply
well it it helps you to hear the poem in
a new way and then when you go back to
it maybe it sort of
helps you read the old poetry in a new
way so so here's an old poem probably
recognize this as a poem by blake to see
a world in a grain of sand
and heaven in a wild flower hold
infinity
in the palm of your hand an eternity in
an hour i always like that one because
it's got a bit of mathematics already in
it um but let's apply n plus seven to
that
to see a worm in a grampus of sand blast
and a [ __ ] in a wild flu
hold inflow in the palmsie of your
hangar an ethos in a house fly
no that is kind of curious
um but you can hear the same
underlying poem there but just something
very new emerging out of there um so i
think some of these you might say well
you know it needs a little bit more of
human creativity in it but i think these
are meant to be
jumping off points to to make you think
it in new ways and and i uh very
exciting this kind of ulipo movement
that they were just looking at
mathematical structures how could they
be used as a kind of shortcut either to
generating huge number of poems or or
thinking about perms in a new way um and
there's uh another one which uh not
poetry which somehow already has a
mathematical character to it but um uh a
novel
which is using a really intriguing piece
of mathematics uh george perek was a
member of the ulupo movement people
might know a book that he wrote which
tried to avoid the letter e
kind of a challenge to translate because
it was in french and then to translate
into english you know the translators
got to do a lot of work but he also
wrote another book called life a user's
manual and this is an interesting book
to use the structure of a latin greco
square i mean they're a bit like
sudoku's they're called latin greco
squares because the idea is can i put
latin letters and greek letters such
that uh you know say four latin letters
four greek letters can i arrange those
such as one of each latin and greek in
each square but you get no repeats on on
columns rows and one of the challenges
was well can you do a five by five six
by six seven by seven and it turns out i
think if i remember rightly that you
can't do six by six but you can do a ten
by ten and it was discovered how to do
that
and parrock took this latin greco square
ten by ten and used it as the structure
for a book with well actually not a
hundred chapters because each box was
going to be a chapter he chooses 99s
there's one of the squares missing
rather provocatively and he puts not
latin and greek letters but lots of
different ideas 10 of this thing and 10
of that thing puts them in all of the
boxes in a way that no box in a row or
column will have a repeat and then he
uses again another mathematical idea the
knights move to move through all of
these rooms and then he sets himself the
condition he's got to write a chapter
involving all the things that are in
that room that he's put using the the 10
by 10 latin greco square so again his
mathematics being used as a structure
and a constraint
in order to be able to push him into
being
inventive in a in a way that he might
not have considered before so i think
that's what's interesting using
mathematics to push you into new realms
sometimes generating new things
sometimes restricting you and using that
you find yourself discovering literature
that you never would have thought of
doing before professor you're a
mathematician
and i know you also like music and the
arts and things like that have you ever
used your own mathematics to create some
kind of constraint on any art you were
creating
i actually in music i have done i worked
with a composer
and we wrote this quartet together
which was the idea that i thought
mathematical proof was a bit like
writing a piece of music what i did was
to explain to emily howard this composer
four of my favorite proofs from the
ancient greeks and then she used those
as a constraint for her own musical
journeys we ended up writing this string
quartet called four musical proofs and a
conjecture which used sort of the
constraint of
the logical journey of a mathematical
proof as a way of inspiring new music a
lot of this stuff that you've shared
with me in this video like is fun but it
does say you use the word absurd which i
think is a good word for it like do you
think this is like silliness is this
doing a good service to the art or is
this like are people going to watch this
video and think what a load of nonsense
uh well i i do think the uh movement has
certainly um had those criticism leveled
at them and i think uh sometimes the
things just generate
perhaps that sonnet you felt was
completely meaningless but every now and
again maybe it helps you
to discover a real gem and i think if
you look at people who use
those kind of ideas of mathematical
structures as an inspiration
you realize that it can be sometimes
very profitable i mean take calvino
italian
novelist who used a lot of these kind of
generative ideas he wrote a lovely book
called cosmic comics which i recommend
any scientists to read because they're
full of wonderful little scientific
ideas to create literature you know he's
a a great novelist but he used
mathematics as an inspiration for a lot
of his ideas the other one i would
suggest is borges borges he's one of my
literary heroes and he used lovely ideas
and mathematics for example the library
of babel is a story short story 10 pages
it makes this library that actually when
you explore the library through the
literature through the story you realize
that what borges has created is a
folded-up library that has three
different directions you can go in you
know along the floor but up the floors
as well and he connects them all
together when you connect these light
these floors and rooms together the
shape of this library is actually the
surface of a four-dimensional tourist he
wanted to explore these mathematical
ideas
using his own language of storytelling
sometimes it doesn't produce something
uh which is interesting but every now
and again you get a gem which comes out
of this one last question professor
you've talked a bit about how the arts
borrow from mathematics and can benefit
from it and it can help get through
writer's block does it ever go the other
way does mathematics ever benefit from
art
yeah i think that's a real challenge and
i think you know i'm
i talk a lot to different artists uh
from different disciplines music
literature theater and i'm always
looking for something interesting which
has started in the arts and then
stimulates something mathematically
actually
the fibonacci numbers are numbers which
were first discovered by poets and
musicians
because the fibonacci numbers count the
number of rhythms you can make with long
and short beats so a poet that wanted to
create
a poem with long and short beats
actually uh
discovered these fibonacci numbers so
there's an interesting sort of different
direction rather unexpected
but i actually have been inspired to
look at a new mathematical structure
in my kind of own area of research which
was stimulated by
listening to a piece of music that was
exploring the symmetries of the cube
combined with a fibonacci kind of uh
sequence sort of it was doing symmetries
but using a fibonacci rule to generate
the next symmetry and i'd never seen
that before a combination of fibonacci
and symmetry and so that piece of music
seeing these composers and narcos use
that has actually set me off on a
journey saying well what about other
symmetrical structures and if you do
this fibonacci rule are there new things
you can discover so my own research has
actually benefited from uh
from exploration by a musician about uh
kind of mathematical ideas
you know maybe you've written millions
of poems or if you're like me you've
made what feels like millions of videos
one thing for sure is you don't want to
lose all that stuff to a computer
failure or maybe something even worse a
backup at home just isn't going to cut
it you need a backup in the cloud and
for that i use backblaze easy to use
great value for money you know nothing
gives me more peace of mind than seeing
this little icon in the top right corner
of my screen knowing all my files have
been constantly updated and backed up to
the cloud if the worst does happen don't
worry you can then get all your stuff
back from the cloud or if it's a lot
maybe you can have it sent by post on a
hard drive you can also access any file
anytime from say your mobile phone which
is a feature i have found very handy
from time to time go to backblaze.com
number five to check them out they have
a free 15 day trial with no strings
attached so i can't hurt to have a look
backblaze.com
numberphile there'll be a link in the
video description
while sharks to let's say potted shrimps
are prone
to one sweet hour of bliss my memory
clings
filching the lolly country thrift held
save
he's gone to london how the echo rings